sabemos que podemos encontrar el área de
un rectángulo multiplicando la base por
la altura el área de un rectángulo es
igual a la base por la altura en otro
vídeo vimos que si estamos buscando el
área de un paralelogramo y también
conocemos la longitud de la base y
conocemos su altura el área seguirá
siendo la base por la altura y no es tan
obvio cuando vemos el paralelogramo pero
en este vídeo manipulamos un poquito el
paralelogramo dijimos vamos a tomar esta
área de aquí la quitamos y la movimos
hacia el lado derecho y con esto nos
dimos cuenta que siempre y cuando
conozcamos la base y la altura como en
este rectángulo de aquí arriba voy a
poder reconstruir un rectángulo moviendo
esta área y es por eso que el área de
este paralelogramo es base por altura no
agregue ni quite área de aquí
simplemente la moví del lado izquierdo
al lado derecho y lo hice para
mostrarles que el área del paralelogramo
es la misma que el área del recto
seguirá siendo base por altura y espero
que esto los haya convencido de que el
área de un paralelogramo es base por
altura ya que usaremos esa misma
intuición para encontrar en el área de
un triángulo veamos unos triángulos aquí
este es un triángulo y nos dan la base y
la altura y vamos a tratar de encontrar
el área de este triángulo y se pueden
imaginar que esta área depende de la
base y de la altura para pensar en ello
permítanme copiar y pegar ese triángulo
lo copiamos y lo pegamos y ahora tenemos
dos triángulos iguales tenemos el doble
de la misma área y ahora voy a rotar en
este triángulo de acá
y la voy a agregar al área original y
verdad que algo muy interesante está
sucediendo
ahora he construido un paralelogramo que
tiene el doble del área de nuestro
triángulo original
comenzamos con dos triángulos iguales
ustedes vieron cómo lo copiaba y lo
pegaba y después lo volteé para poder
construir ese paralelogramo y porque
esto es interesante bueno sabemos que el
área de todo el paralelogramo va a ser
la longitud de esta base multiplicada
por la altura y bueno aquí también
tenemos la altura pero con la h
invertida es base por altura el cálculo
del área del paralelogramo vamos a
dibujar el paralelogramo aquí para que
nos quede claro que este es el área de
un paralelogramo y cuál será el área de
nuestro triángulo original el área de
este triángulo original pues ya vimos
que esta área del paralelogramo es el
doble del área del triángulo original
por lo que nuestro triángulo original va
a tener la mitad del área del
paralelogramo esta área es igual a
a mitad de esta otra área un medio por
la base por la altura y a lo mejor
ustedes pueden decirme bueno si eso
funcionó para este triángulo pero quiero
ver si funciona para otros triángulos
diferentes
para ayudarnos aquí tengo otro triángulo
diferente y pueden ver que es un
triángulo obtuso este ángulo de aquí es
mayor que 90 grados pero quiero hacer lo
mismo tenemos la base tenemos la altura
podríamos imaginarnos que si estamos en
este punto y dejáramos caer una pelota
la pelota caería directamente hacia
abajo podríamos imaginar que ese es el
nivel del suelo y hasta aquí llega la
pelota que tiramos desde arriba esta va
a ser la altura no está dentro del
triángulo como lo vimos en el ejemplo
anterior pero sigue siendo la altura del
triángulo si esto fuera un edificio de
algún tipo podríamos decir que ésta
sigue siendo la altura de ese edificio
si dejáramos caer algo desde arriba nos
indica qué tan lejos del suelo se
encuentra cuál será el área de esto
bueno se pueden imaginar que es un medio
por la base por la altura como es que
sabemos que esto se cumple bueno vamos a
hacer lo mismo que en el ejemplo
anterior
vamos a copiar y pegar esto y ahora
tengo dos de estos triángulos pero vamos
a voltear este de aquí de manera que
podamos crear un paralelogramo lo
rotamos y lo movemos acá y voy a rotarlo
un poquito mejor para que coincidan y
con esto creo que tiene la idea general
de manera que ahora he construido un
paralelogramo que tiene el doble del
área del triángulo original y si
quisiera calcular el área de todo el
paralelogramo sería la base por la
altura del paralelo gramo pero si solo
estamos hablando de esta área que es
nuestro triángulo original tendrá la
mitad del área del paralelogramo el área
de nuestro triángulo original es un
medio por la base por la altura y espero
que con esto ustedes se sientan con toda
la confianza de usar esta fórmula para
calcular el área de cualquier triángulo
el área de cualquier triángulo es un
medio por la base por la altura y el
área de un rectángulo paralelogramo va a
ser la base por la altura